she want heck of two roof lights uh the
St frame furniture and Scar her cions
what uh mat and Sh by C Brad couldn't
give us too much of his time or well
maybe he could have done but I didn't
want to impose on him too much CU you
know I was flattered enough that he
wanted to be in our film
anyway mastering an English accent is a
tricky old thing and uh I couldn't see
where he was going to fit in as a Brit
it's not English how are you kind for
thees you know it's just well it's just
but the great thing about um this
ARS Gypsy thing is that you know he's
not he's not really an Irish Gypsy he's
just a gypsy with a bit of an Irish tint
to him so um and he's not you're not
really supposed to understand what
you're saying do you like dags dags what
yeah dags DS you like DS at some point
they were debating how quirky and funny
it would be to subtitle the $20 million
actor